weil sie sind auf platz zwei der liste
für die wahl zum europäischen parlament
das heißt sie sind wie können die
sektkorken knallen lassen sie sind ganz
sicher im europäischen parlament aber
wahrscheinlich werden sie sich dort kaum
wohlfühlen weil ihre partei möchte ja
gerade dieses parlament ja zum teufel
jagen
also wir möchten die eu reformieren wir
möchten ja vieles verändern und wir
möchten vor allem ausmisten und ich
glaube da sind auch menschen mit
gesundem menschenverstand genau richtig
und diesen part möchte ich übernehme
gerne die lust der afg mitglieder auf
die europäische union ist aber nicht
sehr entwickelt bei einer
mitgliederumfrage haben 89 prozent der
alf teammitglieder gesagt raus aus der
europäischen union wenn es nicht die
reformen gibt die die afg anstrebt
die aber wahrscheinlich nicht umgesetzt
werden also erstmal denke ich wir sind
die partei die mehr demokratie will die
hat volg einbeziehen möchte ich finde
bei so einer wichtigen entscheidung
müssen wir eine volksabstimmung haben
und eigentlich nichts anderes wollen wir
eine volksabstimmung über die frage eu
nun jetzt sind wir erst in der
europäischen union ja eigentlich schon
seit 1957 die hits - damals noch anders
warum dann nach so vielen jahren die
volksabstimmung ja angefangen habe war
ein 50 sogar mit kohle und stahl also im
prinzip haben die bergleute und
stahlkocher europa erfunden aber
tatsächlich nie demokratisch legitimiert
jedenfalls nicht in deutschland in
anderen ländern hat volksabstimmung
stattgefunden auch zur euro frage auch
zur verfassungsfrage in deutschland hat
er gleich in die stadt gefunden und
dafür wird es endlich zeit stahlkocher
und bergleute ist ein schönes stichwort
sie haben zumindest in der partei führen
eine art alleinstellungsmerkmal
sie sind mit und in der spd im
ruhrgebiet aufgewachsen eine klassische
spd biografie sie waren steiger im
bergbau gewesen und sind jetzt in der
afg sie planen ja eine art bundesweiter
gewerkschaft auf dna gewerkschaft wenn
man sich jetzt aber mal die
wählerwanderungen in den letzten monaten
an zidan hat die afg sehr viele
ehemalige spd wähler überzeugen können
von sich das sind gerade
gewerkschaftlich organisierte
arbeitnehmer gewesen
so jedenfalls die demoskopen ist hier
habe ja eigentlich schon diejenigen die
sie da anwerben wollen
wir sind tatsächlich im moment die
arbeiterpartei nummer 1 also der fc
steht bei den arbeitern ganz vorne dann
kommt die linkspartei und dann
irgendwann ziemlich abgeschlagen die
ehemalige arbeiterpartei die spd
und selbst eher um fragen des dgb ist
sagen dass gewerkschaftsmitglieder
überproportional stark die afw wählen
und deswegen finde ich gerade diesen
gedanken eine alternative gewerkschaft
zu haben unglaublich wichtig also wir
haben hier ein riesenpotenzial
besonders in der automobilindustrie zum
beispiel da ist ganz viel luft nach oben
und das ist eine ganz spannende aufgabe
und die werde ich in zukunft sehr
intensiv betreiben also wir brauchen
unbedingt eine alternative gewerkschaft
obwohl sie eigentlich schon viele
gewerkschaft auf ihrer seite haben ja
genau also wählten sie uns sowieso aber
warum dann eine eigene gewerkschaft weil
wir endlich die gewerkschaften brauchen
die daten macht was jedoch
betriebsverfassung zu setzen sollten sie
um ihre mitglieder kümmern und um nichts
anderes
wir haben im moment in den genen
gewerkschaftsbund der ganz viel politik
macht er sehr viel wert darauf legt den
herrschenden hier herrschten hier zu
unterstützen und dann brauchen wir
überhaupt nicht eine gewerkschaft muss
nichts anderes machen als die interessen
ihrer mitglieder zu vertreten und das
brauchen wir
die wollen ja auch dass die jeweiligen
unternehmen gewinne machen und damit
auch arbeitsplätze schaffen
aber gerade diese unternehmen sind ja
vom export abhängig deswegen die frage
warum sind sie so europa gegenüber
also wir sind überhaupt nicht kritisch
europa gegenüber also der kontinent das
land die kultur das gefällt uns da wohl
mehr von und nicht weniger
und ich kann mich erinnern an zeiten da
gab es noch die europäische gemeinschaft
die haben wir glaube ich alle als wahren
grund positiver wahrgenommen
offene grenzen hintergrund positiver ist
die freihandelszone von grund positive
das wollen wir alles was wir nicht
wollen ist dieses buch a tree monster
brüssel
damit haben wir probleme und mit nichts
anderem sind sie froh dass andre
poggenburg weg ist ganz ehrlich ich bin
froh gott sei dank
also leute wie andre poggenburg können
wir nicht gebrauchen und ich bin froh
für jeden der seine geisteshaltung teilt
und ihm folgt chance auch der säuberung
der fc in eine ganz große chance jeden
tatsächlich ist etwa wir haben den einen
oder anderen verrückten da sind nur ganz
wenige
aber die gibt es tatsächlich und ich bin
glücklich über jeden der diese partei
verletzt sie sind ja vor allen dingen
wegen der flüchtlingspolitik aus der spd
ausgetreten war das eigentlich wirklich
ein hinreichender grund ja auf jeden
fall also wir haben großes problem dass
diese ehemalige arbeiter partei sich
nicht nur um ihr kind gekümmert sondern
um allerlei randgruppen
wir brauchen endlich wieder eine partei
die sich um ihre leute gemacht um uns
und da ist die afg mit
einzige partei die hat glaubwürdig macht
und die einzige partei die die echten
probleme in unserem land anspricht wie
die währungskrise wie die energiewende
und eben die 50 problematik das sind
echte reale probleme aber es ist ein
unterschied ob man jemanden oder politik
kritisiert weil die flüchtlingspolitik
unkoordiniert ist oder ob man politik
koordiniert weil man einfach eine bunte
vielfältige gesellschaft nicht möchte
also ich bin ein großer freund von einer
bunten vielfältigen gesellschaft nur die
muss gesteuert werden
und die muss tatsächlich zu einer
bereicherung führen deswegen brauchen
wir ein einwanderungsgesetz sagen wir
ganz klipp und klar und aber die
menschen die da zu uns kommen die sollen
eine bereicherung sein das heißt sie
sollen qualifiziert seien
wie in jedem anderen einwanderungsland
auch also gucken sie sich die usa
australien und kanada an
die haben ahnung mit integration die
abmahnung mit einwanderung und die
wissen wie geht wir brauchen im system
wie in kanada wir brauchen ein
punktesystem
wir brauchen die leute die was können
die qualifizierten die müssen wir an
verben ganz dringend soweit guido reil
demnächst im europäischen parlament
beisitzer im bundesvorstand der fdp
herzlichen dank für das gespräch